the fucsia did you try the walrus I have
not I've not run in tonight f3 I don't
think if I did run in tonight f3 I
probably forgot to play the walrus but
let's play a new opponents talkie thanks
for the bits I was watching your day
before yesterday video the three hour
long one I did fall asleep for the third
time watching that just whoa go well
good morning
our wait you just woke up oh you fell
asleep for the third time ah yeah
sometimes our sleep inducing okay I'm
playing the walrus against a massively
high rated player I don't know why this
is not the best type of peer pressure
but I'm going insane it's a walrus don't
mess with a walrus
unless wait what do I do here let's a
take and let's try and win back the pawn
97 to g6 okay first time in my life
playing the walrus if I lose I'll blame
it on the fukes eeeh if you're
introducing me to this this is nonsense
at least I have a time advantage have
Queen e7 but then 95 is annoying
I could take mmm I can play H 5 H 4 well
it's just Castle I don't know I'm so
conflicted let's just Castle Ricky aids
trying to win back the pawn and not lose
everything
I'll take with night takes I'll probably
take with rook I want to play d6 next
each files opening remember the bishop
can help attack and defend I'd see for
ideas maybe [ __ ] f5 first I would
actually like the B file to open
send rook b8 and my rook and Bishop can
coordinate along with my nights I'd c4
is the main idea maybe Queen f6 Knight
c4 later take on b2 I was half-expecting
some like 94 Bishop a4 but then I think
it just runs into night c4 ok White's
thinking
efore mmm you force night c4 Queen d3
let's just be safe this is like a big
pawn these bishops keep the King safe at
least for now
I'm not even down upon I should move the
Queen 95 coming I'll have to deal with
it
Knight d5 Knight c4 is interesting and
then we're both trying to attack each
other in Bishop h3 you just the Queen
can come over and not have three ideas
some idea Knight c 4b 5b 4 when in doubt
I just have to pretend that I'm a walrus
whoa 95 94 what's going on
I should do it or should I not sure it's
complicated
maybe Queenie six but then Bishop h3
their rookie six but still Bishop h3
mm-hmm there's queen bee five
it's complicated
okay let's try this calculating Queen
before and then I can take in b5
okay night have six I have to take it
and suffer on the dark squares
hopefully not suffer too badly have a
five ideas this King is also weak it's a
line with my bishop
whoa this move so there there
I win d1 and end it's a mess calf did go
for this that's a big mess how many
pawns do I have for the two pieces rook
and Oh working to pond no yeah working
coupons for two pieces so it's still a
fight this night is a bit awkward it's
coming back to life
hmm rook b4 maybe before initiative can
this move and then this move
ooh attack upon Knights also hanging
let's take a thing if take sigh rook c8
and takes you to want to play this move
next King be one expected rook a four
will be next
Knight takes rook c4 camera playing in
situ oh but then 97 so work c5 first
attack the knight look c4 back maybe
came out five king power ah okay let's
just walk up with a king and hope
everything is okay attacking the pawn
look past a pawn oh dear or it takes f7
I don't see any great discoveries for
for whites I fee and cattle my king and
rook c7 to keep the time advantage a six
solid ah what's going on oh this is
scary
play rook d1 I'm so terrified just have
to pretend that I'm a walrus Guinea -
yeah go away
there we go
time advantage dirty flag dirty flag so
sorry - my opponent that's the nature of
lits lavoris lives on undefeated with
the walrus I don't know if I've taken
any pictures of a walrus have to go to
the zoo and find out but yeah for people
watching in the future on YouTube don't
mess with the walrus